Hey guys, hope you're doing good in the chapter. I'm going to teach you my personal approach
to CRD or Gandal range theory. Now I explained this concept over one and a half years ago
on my YouTube, but it wasn't really in that much detail. I just told you guys that candles
are ranges and basically you can take a turtle soup whenever the candle high is taken out
or the candle low is taken out. Now a lot of people on Twitter consider this as their
own concept. It is not my concept. It is not their concept. This is all ICT. There's nothing
that someone invented, right? Someone else invented. This is all ICT. So what exactly
is CRD? So CRD is Gandal range theory, right? Every candle is a range and that is absolutely
obvious, right? That there's nothing new to it. But then there are some timings that
if we focus on, you know, you can trade with very high probability. So although every single
candle is a range, it doesn't mean that every single candle's range is high probability.
We have specific times that make those candle ranges high probability. So the number one
is one M for our candle. So this is a four hour candle and this is also a four hour candle.
Okay. So we're going to have two high probability turtle soups in a day. Now one can work and
one cannot work or both total soups can work in a day. So basically you will win two trades
in a day. Now don't get confused. I'm going to explain each and everything. All right.
So this may sound a bit complicated, but it is not just listen to me. So this is the
first four hour candle and that's going to open at one M. And then this is the second
four hour candle and that's going to open at five M. So practically we want to wait for
the candle closure. So the one M for our candle needs to close. So once it closes, we are simply
marking out the one M for our candle high and low. Now there are two ways to trade this.
Okay, the very first step is we need to see when the candle closes, right, the one M for our candle,
we have to drop down to five minute time from. And let's suppose that the high is taken out.
Now I want to see a market structure shift.
Also acceptance back into the range, the candle range. So this is the candle range high. This is
the candle range low. Once the candle closes, we are waiting for a rate either to the candle high
or the candle low. So in this example, you can see that the next candle opened here and on the
five minute down from, we took out the four hour candle high. And then we also have a market
structure shift and we also have acceptance back into the range. I want to see price come back
into the range, right? And that's going to increase the probability. Now, I am simply just taking my
entry from the fair valley gap or a breaker block or an auto block. And here is the risk management
for this strategy. You take your entry, put your stock right above the high and you close 50% of
your position at one to one ratio ratio. So once you reach one to one, you are basically
taking 50% of your position. And then you're also going break even. Now, you are leaving the
trade till the candle low is taken out. So this is going to maximize the profits. Now, the second
way to trade is you have a period rate on the four hour time from this is a four hour candle.
On the four time, let's suppose that you have a fair valley gap. Now, once price takes out the
four hour candle high, and it also taps into a period rate, and then gives you a market structure
shift on the five minute down from that makes it high probability. Okay, there are always some ways
to increase the probabilities of the strategy. All right, and that's what I'm teaching. My goal
is to teach you ways that you can approach this strategy. And there are two ways. One is, of course,
going to have low probability, but it's not a huge difference. If you're in account for PDRAs,
your win rate is going to just go five to 10% higher. That's it. But it's not very significant when
when you're going to win these massive trades. So you take 50% off at one to one, and then you
basically hold till this level. Now, of course, I'm going to give you examples and your confusion
will be gone. So it's very simple, just five minute market structure shift. Now, here is one
scenario that can occur, right? So let's assume, just let me just let me just remove this. The new
candle opens, you have price keeps going up, right? And then you get a market structure shift. Now,
I will not take my entry. Why? Because price didn't come back into the range. So even though price can
go here, and I want to see price close below the range. So now once it does that,
right? Let me just remove this. Once it does that, then I can look to take my entry from any
PDRA that is present, right? So I can basically just consider this as an auto blog and then take
my entry. I just want to see price come back into the range. So very simple guys. Now,
here's another thing that you need to know. Okay, this is very important. So if you do not get an
entry before the 5M candle closes, right? So let's suppose that the 1M for our candle closed. But
you know, the rate, the price doesn't take out the 1M candle high or the low. Before
the 5M candle closes. That's going to be around 8, right? Am. I'm going to explain everything when I
go to the live charts, but try to understand what I'm saying. If the rate doesn't happen, right? So
let's suppose price keeps on, you know, consolidating, consolidating, no, right? But then the new candle
opens, the 5M candle opens and, you know, basically, oh, my bad, my bad, my bad, let me explain it
because this is very confusing, right? So the 5M candle open is when you're going to see the
rate, right? So this open is the open of this candle. I hope that makes sense. The open of this
candle is the open of this candle. Just this is just for like, it's a picture to explain things,
right? So if you don't get a rate before the 5M candle closes, then you have to wait for the
rate of the 5M candle. I know it's, it's confusing, right? Don't worry, I'm going to go to the live
charts and it's going to clear each and everything. But if the rate doesn't happen
of this candle, then we have to wait for this candle to close. And then we have to look for
the rate of this candle. This one becomes useless. This candle becomes useless, all right?
Now I'm just going to go to the live charts and I'm going to explain everything so all of your
confusion is going to be over. All right, so here is example one, right? This is the 1M candle
and this is the 5M candle. Now, look at this 1M candle. All you need to do is mark out the high
and the low of that candle. Very simple, all right? Now if I drop down to 5M time frame,
you can see that this was the candle high and it got swept right here. Now we simply look for a
shift in the market structure, right? And around here, we have that. Now I was going to send this
setup today in the discord, but I sent the other one, which was this and it turned out to be a
loser. So very unfortunate, whoever took that trade, this would have been an awesome winner.
You can see that we had this autoblock here, right? This fair value gap as well. This could have been
basically your entry somewhere around here and you would go shot right here, stop right above the
high. At one to one, you would take like 50% or 40% of your trade, go break even and then hold till
here. Now what I sometimes like to do is use my fib from the last high that was formed to the last
low that was formed before market structure shift and I use the standard deviation projections
to take my profits, right? So if the real draw on liquidity, which is the candle low is near the
negative to negative 2.5 or negative four, then it increases the probability of the setup.
So this happened today and it happens every single day. Now I want to give you guys
the peers and assets that this works with. So first off, it works with gold, then it works with
your USD and that works works with NAS 100, USD 30 and S&P 500, all right? You don't have to trade
anything else. Every single day, you choose one pair or asset and then you trade that asset or
pair, all right? You don't have to take two different trades. So for example, if you are
short on gold, you do not want to buy your USD, right? You just have to trade one pair,
whichever presents the setup, don't trade multiple pairs at the same time. So let's move on to the
next example now. Alright guys, so here is example two. So over here you can see that we have a
PD array that is a four hour free value gap, then we have the 5M four hour candle, all right?
So this is the opening price, the candle closes here. So we simply mark out the high and the low
of that candle. So this is a method two where price goes into the PD array. So you can see that the
high of the 5M candle was taken out and price also was in a PD array and this is the candle
low. So this would be a redraw on liquidity. So if I go to the five minute time from now,
I zoom out a bit, you can see that this was this was the high. So this tiny bit, let me just
mark this up like that. So at nine, actually, the can the 5M candle closes at 9M, the 5M candle
closes. Remember that. So we get a clean shift in the market structure. We have this big auto
block. So a good entry point would be this, because that is a BPR. And you can see that this
would have been a short position just right here. You can also take your, you know, usually I would
wait for the extreme level to be taken. But since price is already giving me one to two,
right, there is no need to take your entry from here, because price is giving us decent
risk to reward. Now, you can see that your entry would have been here at one to one,
you would take around 40 to 50% of your position, go break even, right? And then you can see that
the take profit was hit. Your entry, remember must be before 12, always. Okay, 12. So our entry was
at 11 something. So this was a beautiful trade. We tap into PD array, you know, and this is method
too. Let's move on to the next example. All right, guys, so here is another example. And you can see
that we have the one M candle here. Price did take it out, but it went up and you may have got stopped
at break even with one partial. Now, however, if we look at the 5M for our candle, right,
we simply mark out the low and the high of that candle. Okay, so we get we have the one M and the
5M candle. These are important. Now, if I go to the five minute chart here, you can see that after
taking this, we had a shift in the market structure. So you can account for weeks as well for this
strategy. And most importantly, we closed back above the range above this low.
Then we have the auto blog, right, a very clean trade. And if we use our standard deviation tool,
although the draw on liquidity is here, there's a higher draw on liquidity that might be here.
So this around here, because it is above the negative two. So this could be your final
take profit level, right? Let me just close this real quick. So this could be your final take profit
level. So a very beautiful entry from this auto blog here. And it played out perfectly. And this
strategy works really well for some reason with US study, right? If you want like insane consistency,
then I suggest you trade this because it has like a very, very high win rate for this, like,
asset. Let me give you guys one more example. And then I will end this chapter.
All right, guys. So here is the final example. And I'm looking at the one M candle. So I'm going
to mark out the low. And I'm going to mark out the high. Now do note that we are inside this
PRA. This is a auto block, right? A bullish auto block. So that increases the probabilities.
Always remember that. And one key thing to note, we are in the discount. So that is also a plus
point. These small things, if you try to implement them in every strategy that I've taught you,
your win rate is going to improve. All right. So the one M candle low was taken out for us.
So let's study what happened. So if I go here, right, the low was taken out first.
And notice what happened. This has to be the cleanest example. We swept this low. We broke
the structure market structure. We also broke the structure. Very nice. Then we have this
fair value gap. Look at the precision here. The bodies were beautifully respected.
So this could have been a long position. Your stop would go right below this low.
And at one to one. Somewhere around here, right? One, two, one. This is the entry.
Probably goes up here. So let me just do that. You would go break even somewhere around here.
And then you can see that if you held till here, this would have given you a beautiful
restore what ratio. So this is pretty much it. Right. So
let me just show you one thing. This is very important. So notice this. Okay.
This is. So let's assume that this is the one M candle and this is the five M candle. All right.
Now let's say that you mark out the low and the high of the one M candle. But you see that
the high and low were not taken out in the next candle, which is the five M candle.
So now we want to stop looking at this candle and we're going to mark out the high and low of
the five M candle. Why? Because the five M candle could not couldn't take out the high low of the
one M candle. I repeat, if the high or the low of the one M candle is not taken out between the
five M candle, then we wait for the five M candle to close. And then we mark out the five M candle
high and low. Right. And that's where our focus is going to go. We forget about the one M candle.
And then we look for the purge of the five M low and we target the high. So thank you so much
for watching. Please practice. All right. Just by watching this and trading this on the live
market is not going to help you go and back test and see the results by yourself.